hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what I eat in a date youtuber reviews
I'm gonna be taking a look at Stephanie
Joshi from the YouTube channel nutty
foodie fitness now Stephanie is a model
and fitness enthusiast and is known for
her what I eat in a day videos and
eating challenges some examples of the
food challenge videos on her channel
include the ever so popular
ten thousand calorie challenge only
eating sweet food for 24 hours eating
peanut butter for 24 hours eating
nothing but pizza for a day you get the
gist
this also sounds eerily similar to our
friend Olivia Adams from always hungry
but I am hoping we get a little bit of a
different narrative from Stephanie now
Before we jump into my review I want to
start with my general disclaimer that
the information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always seek out the
help of a registered dietitian or a
medical professional for your unique
case also I want to specifically flag
that some of the behaviors in these
videos may be triggering to some members
of my audience who may have a history of
disordered eating so if this does sound
like you feel free to skip over this
video I also want to remind everybody to
please be kind in the comments let's
keep this community supportive
let's meet Stephanie and take a look at
her first meal of the day I did well I'm
not gonna be eating today I don't know
about you guys but shops around here
struggling even to get hold of oats
potatoes pasta they won't be in this
video I do also just wanna point out
that I was about to start the video my
mom goes this is the first makeup on in
two weeks so if you're thinking I'm
glowing up everyday in the house okay so
like the vast majority of us right now
Stephanie is currently in self-isolation
and let's just say the struggle is real
I can totally relate to the stress of
not finding the usual essential food
items at the store nowadays I would say
that it's more than a disappointment
when your go-to staples aren't available
for me it is actually really stressful
because you know I know that I can't
just pick it up somewhere else so easily
so also you guys need to know that I
wash my hair for all of you today and I
am doing that legit like once a week
because I only see you guys like once a
week so yeah my hair and my nails and my
skin better look amazing after all of
this is done let's take a look at what
she has for breakfast on day one it's
topped with apple cinnamon and blueberry
raspberry granola exquisite so good oh
my gosh what a gorgeous oatmeal Bowl and
I love the apple pie flavor now I'm a
big fan of oats in the morning because
they are rich in carbohydrates and fiber
to keep you satiated and the specific
fiber that is found in oats
beta glucan has been shown to help lower
cholesterol which is probably not an
issue for Stephanie but is a really huge
selling point for a lot of other adults
one thing we need to be mindful of of
course is balancing out those carbs with
a source of protein especially at
breakfast
now that could potentially come from the
milk that's added to the oats but since
stephanie is using a milk alternative
like oat milk the protein content is
kind of lacking so even though we have a
good amount of cars from the oats the
Apple and some granola on top and also
some healthy fats from the chia seeds I
would love to see some extra protein
from some maybe some protein powder or
Greek yogurt or a little more Chia or
hemp on top or she could do an egg or
two on the side let's take a look at day
2 the video should be stone
other people strange for the day I can
enjoy we have pancakes
it's dangerous they should have known to
not leave ok YUM
now here we are seeing Stephanie eating
a substantially larger breakfast than
she did on day one she mentions already
having eaten oats for breakfast and then
she has a bite of her your friends
leftover scrambled eggs she has two
pieces of toast with smoked salmon egg
and avocado and two pancakes I mean it's
a lot of food but I think we can all
relate to the hotel brunch effect I will
call it it's actually quite normal to
eat more than you may normally while
you're traveling partially because you
might be walking more you might have
more food options available to you or
you're just influenced by the eating
patterns of others around you having
said that it still does feel like a lot
of food at once in comparison to her day
one breakfast now I am still just
learning about Stephanie so I don't know
if she just has like a normal hearty
appetite or if this is like a cheap day
or eating challenge situation I mean
we'll have to see but I do know a lot of
people who are stuck in diet culture
find that having a big cheat meal like
breakfast can kind of trigger and set
them up for a binge the rest of the day
so it's kind of like the oh I just blew
my diet might as well continue down this
course for the rest of the day and then
tighten up the reigns tomorrow so I am
interested to see how the rest of that
day unfolds but first breakfast number
three
[Music]
Wow my teeth gene a minute okay so this
one'll breakfast looks so great and it's
definitely my favorite of the three
we've got you know healthy carbs from
the oats and the banana protein from the
salted caramel protein powder that she
put in there some peanut butter for some
healthy fats so this would be a more
balanced option than her day one oatmeal
Bowl but just as delicious she also
added in some toffee flavored drops
which have no calories and no sugar or
fat they're basically just like a
sweetener made with sucralose which is
like Splenda along with some natural
flavors and caramel color syrup so
that's a fine add in if you want to cut
back on sugar but if you haven't already
watched my video on artificial
sweeteners you can check it out right
here now let's see what's next
[Music]
basically just start this within seconds
I've probably had about 20 combined okay
so we clearly have a peanut butter lover
on her hands which makes sense in the
context of her moniker so after her
oatmeal breakfast stephanie is having a
little apple with 20 spoonfuls of peanut
butter as a mid-morning snack now I love
the combination of apples and nut butter
because we've got fibre we've got
protein with our healthy fats but the
ratio of Apple to nut butter in this
situation is a little off okay so nut
butter is really energy dense so it is
very easy to eat a large amount of
calories in a small package which is
amazing for those trying to gain weight
or bulk up and as Stephanie sort of
mentions later on in her videos she does
refer to going to the gym to make gain
so this may be the case for her but for
most people one or two tablespoons would
be sufficient for a balanced snack and
20 tablespoons might look a little bit
like a binge again I'm still getting to
know Stephanie style so obviously I am
NOT making any assumptions she does
however mention that she has four
different jars of peanut butter beside
her bed which may be triggering for some
people I actually always recommend
keeping food in the kitchen or pantry
and actually put in your food in a bowl
or on a plate so that you can eat out of
that rather than mindlessly snacking out
of a jar or big bag if you're still
hungry after you finish the food that
you have in your bowl by all means go
get more but eating food in a more
purposeful way just really helps you get
more in tune with your hunger and
fullness cues as you move through your
intuitive eating journey let's take a
look at lunch just want to say that I
have actually been not sponsored I think
it was that step stay sassy my protein
event in a good
Bagon they're just basically gummies
firm for hair strengthening and I feel
like I lose a lot of hair you just have
a lot more hair when I was younger so I
take these and I have just received
another kind of bundle of vitamins from
my protein ok so Stephanie mentions a
few supplements that she has not sure if
she's necessarily taking them or that
she's just promoting them as an
affiliate but a few things to note on
this one just a reminder to influencers
to always disclose your partnerships at
the top of the video I think I've said
that enough and - let's talk about hair
strengthening supplements now I have no
clue what's in that particular gummy
because she doesn't say but speaking
from a nutrition perspective there are
several vitamins and minerals that
certainly play a role in hair growth and
strengthening including vitamin A B
vitamins C D iron zinc and protein
however it's really important to note
that these natural supplements are not
well regulated meaning many of them are
not approved by the FDA so there's
really no real research to prove whether
or not certain supplements like a hair
supplement even work to strengthen your
hair and the claims a lot of these
companies make are truly off base so I'm
not necessarily suggesting that they do
not work they might help but having a
balanced healthy diet that includes all
of these nutrients and of course good
hair jeans which she clearly does is
also really key let's take a look what
she's having for lunch why not bacon
people are gonna be like noodles that's
not a thing
okay so before this meal she did have a
little mini workout in the kitchen doing
some push-ups which looked great and
then shortly after we're seeing a
classic English breakfast with bacon
eggs garlic mushrooms tomatoes noodles a
bagel and some baked beans I didn't even
know the Brits had noodles for breakfast
but I don't know my British fans out
there it's not common because I totally
love to know these things so leave me a
comment below anyways lots going on here
so we've got the protein from the baked
beans bacon and eggs
we've got some Veggie action from the
tomatoes and mushrooms yes I know
tomatoes are fruit but you get what I'm
saying
carbs from the bagel and the noodles she
also was not afraid to add fat to her
meal as she coated the frying pan with
some butter which is refreshing to see
given the no oil trend is so rampant in
the wellness community but I will say if
she wanted to balance out the higher
amounts of saturated fat from the bacon
eggs and the butter she could have opted
for an unsaturated fat like olive oil
for cooking in this is a hearty meal and
definitely one that is higher in animal
fat and more refined carbs and I would
necessarily recommend regularly but we
are living in unusual times right now so
it is totally normal for your eating
patterns to be unusual a lot of us are
turning to more comfort foods while in
isolation and that is totally okay
that's totally normal
in fact I've talked about that
extensively in this video right here so
I am okay with these kinds of meals in
moderation especially in the context of
Stephanies day because she did have a
lower fat lower protein breakfast with
the oats let's take a look at day - this
is vegan chocolate orange okay so that
guy knows where it's at
chocolate orange combo that is the worst
I mean like this video if you agree
actually I'm just kidding because I know
some people love that combo but okay so
after their epic hotel brunch
it looks like stephanie is doing a
little kind of tour of a protein powder
factory which i think is the same
protein powder that she is an affiliate
for but anyways it now makes sense that
she wanted to have a larger meal because
she was going to be out and about before
she could eat again I mean this is
actually super typical for travel days
so I'm glad that she was able to
anticipate her day and plan her eating
accordingly though it does look like she
was at least able to get some little
samples of the protein drinks as a bit
of a snack let's see what's next
so that's what they have these yep just
nightlife chose me
okay so now Stephanie is on the way to
the gym with her friends and we see that
she has a BCAA beverage and some truffle
chocolates which is later followed up
with a fruit smoothie now this actually
looks like a pretty good pre-workout
snack we're getting some of those fast
digesting carbs from the fruit smoothie
which you would actually want to have
prior to a workout to give you some
energy plus we have the BCA a supplement
now BCAAs Stanford branch chain amino
acids and they're commonly taken as a
supplement containing three essential
amino acids leucine isoleucine and
valine while there is some research that
BCAAs may aid in muscle soreness and
fatigue and muscle mass most research
does not suggest that this is
necessarily superior to getting a
complete source of protein with all
essential amino acids from a more
cost-effective food or a supplement like
whey protein so by all means take the
cia's to support your workout if you
find they are working for you but you
can also get adequate amounts in your
diet from foods like tofu beans meat
poultry fish eggs pumpkin seeds and
quinoa
apparently TJ is forcing me into
training a little bit so we're going a
little bit naughty Beauty Fitness needs
to do some fitness okay so given that
Stephanie's larger-than-normal breakfast
that day she doesn't actually have a
full lunch this day it's basically just
the supplements and the smoothie which
is probably because she's not that
hungry
even though she does say that she kind
of wants to go have lunch and not really
train now I am glad that she did get
some fuel in the tank with the
pre-workout and you know hopefully she
is just listening to her body's needs
rather than pulling a typical cheat day
stunt where she starts the day off with
a larger than normal meal and then says
oh spirit I guess I'll just eat
everything that I can so far this is
looking pretty balanced but let's take a
look at day three smoked salmon coming
go smoothie coming
or happiness pancake cheese tortellini
because can you have enough cheese in
the morning happiness pancakes with
pistachio sauce salmon avocado 3 cheese
oh my gosh
where is this restaurant honestly the
food looks amazing and almost too pretty
to eat to be honest but also I think the
girl lidget ordered everything on the
menu and it looks like she did a pretty
good job polishing it all off I mean
down to the balsamic glaze on her plate
so we have a layered smoothie pancakes
avocado toast on a waffle chicken
sandwich with salad cheese tortellini
and a pistachio doughnut that has a
total of five lunch entrees and a
dessert it's hard to know if she's
shared everything or not but regardless
it is a large amount of food so I am a
bit concerned that this is teetering in
kind of eating challenge she'd a
territory but let's take a look at her
snacks so after a carb heavy breakfast
and then a fat and protein heavy lunch
we are back for a sweet treat here for
afternoon tea let's see what else she's
having for snack
any commentary whilst making this bomb
match a peanutbutter dessert watching
the news but you can thank me later
whoa okay so this matcher chia pudding
like concoction that Stephanie is made
for her snack is pretty genius I have to
say though it does have a desert-like
feel with the matcha KitKat in there it
still is pretty nutrient dense so we've
got some protein from the protein powder
and yogurt healthy fast from the chia
seed and the peanut butter and then cars
from the banana and granola and of
course also the Kit Kat I will say in
combination though with the two cake
slices that she already had we're
definitely racking up the added sugar so
far we've seen 150 grams of added sugar
in this day alone and we still have
meals to come now I would show you day
twos snack which again was her
restaurant travel day but she doesn't
have another snack so let's move on to
day three I'll show you what happens
before one makes games this my friends
is a fresh tub of the peanut butter to
share this experience with you guys I
can smell it already
a beautiful sight I can't even explain
how a fresh tub of peanut butter makes
me feel there's extra nuts in that
that's extra nutty oh my god look extra
peanut e oh my mouth is watering like I
can't actually do this without my
singing mmm
okay so based on this short little clip
it appears as Stephanie eats spoonfuls
of peanut butter as her pre-workout
snack on this day though we don't see
how many she has exactly
she is coming off the heels of a massive
brunch meal so I can imagine she's
feeling pretty full from that but also
this is the same day that she had 20
spoonfuls of peanut butter
so I really can't be sure where
relationship with food and her appetite
is that day now from a more practical
nutrition stance I would say straight up
peanut butter is not the best
pre-workout snack the fat slows down the
rate of digestion and it doesn't deliver
the fast-acting carbs that we really
need to perform ideally we want to have
the majority of the fat in our day
spaced out away from our workouts so
maybe if she was hungry before she
trained a combination of carbs and a
little protein would have been a better
choice so exact amounts of course would
depend on the length of time between
when she ate last and when she hit the
gym but if let's say Stephanie eight
thirty minutes before her workout she
would want to aim for around fifteen to
maybe thirty grams of carbs which might
look like a banana or some fruit either
on its own or with some Greek yogurt for
protein to boost up the satiety factor
let's see what dinner has in store
everything and it just the juice is just
we have no other breads
yes I love this I mean I'm a big fan of
slow cooker meals like this and this one
looks so so balanced we've got some
protein from the chickens got cars from
the potato and of course lots of bright
colorful veggies I am really happy to
see that after a sugar heavy snack on
this day we've got a really nutrient
dense meal to end the day let's take a
look at day two are these
I'm hot too and I'm barely wearing any
clothes over check the state okay so for
both people who maybe had a hearty
brunch with lots of carbs in fat I would
say yeah this dinner totally makes sense
we have say changing protein and fat
from the steak and edamame and lots of
edge with the rapini but considering she
just completed a pretty heavy duty
workout I would have liked to see some
carbs in there to really replenish those
glycogen stores let's take a look at day
three and this one meal might tell us a
lot dessert has been taken away for the
time being we have wings we have the
chicken strips dip wings barbecue extra
dip actually clip they're more dip here
it's a vibe it's a vibe and I'm so happy
okay so yeah this was kind of what I was
nervous about with Stephanie's day three
so we have chicken wings chicken strips
coleslaw coke ice cream cookies and a
few different pizzas I mean this scene
is playing out exactly like any mukbang
or cheat day challenge and in the
context of her day with the big ol meal
breakfast peanut butter huge brunch war
peanut butter and now all of this it is
definitely feeling potentially
problematic at one point even her friend
comments on how much she's eaten and I
get that she's trying to make gains but
there are definitely more nourishing
ways to go about that that will satisfy
her nutritional needs without an
excessive amount of saturated fat salt
and sugar now I have to say I am all for
ordering in occasionally and P tonight
is a Friday night tradition in my house
but she's just consumed
90 grams of saturated fat and 15,000 800
milligrams of sodium in this one meal
alone that is 10 times more than the
recommended amount of sodium and 7 times
the amount of saturated fat that is
recommended for one day consuming that
much sodium in one sitting has the
potential to not only cause serious
bloating but over time it can
significantly increase blood pressure
basically a diet that is consistently
high in sodium can injure the blood
vessel walls contributing to plaque
buildup this blocks blood flow which
makes the heart work extra hard to pump
the blood throughout the body and that
increases the risk of heart attack
stroke and heart failure when it comes
to saturated fat and heart health the
research is admittedly quite mixed as
this is a bit of a controversial topic
the relationship between saturated fat
and heart disease is not 100% clear but
Dietary Guidelines do continue to
suggest limiting saturated fat in the
diet because it may have negative
implications for heart health this is a
really complicated topic and I would
need a whole video to get into the minut
details of what kinds of saturated fats
may increase the risk of heart disease
and not regardless I can't necessarily
speak for Stephanie but I would say
consuming 7 times the amount of
saturated fat in one sitting
probably doesn't feel good for most
people let's finish things off with
dessert
final taste test so clearly Stephanie is
eight matcha fan and those look like
such cute little treats
now while matcha may have some brain and
heart health benefits one thing to keep
in mind is that it does have higher
amounts of caffeine than traditional
green tea so these kinds of matcha foods
may not be the best idea to have right
before bed I also feel like she's had a
really sugar heavy day this day as is so
if she were hungry before bed maybe
something like
cheese or yogurt with some fresh fruit
and nuts would have been a more balanced
choice let's see dessert day two we've
got peanut butter cookies Nora's gonna
come and she's gonna be like when did my
cookie go it's quite soft okay Missy
okay so now we know that if we were ever
to go out to eat with Stephanie that we
cannot leave our food unattended but
yeah that all looks so delicious so I
guess it's kind of a good thing that
we're getting some carbs with that
dinner even you know after that heavy
workout like I said but it would have
been really ideal to get more complex
carbs so that we don't get a big sugar
crash in the night now a note about
sugar and sleep well you may feel sleepy
after carb heavy meal aka carb coma
research suggests that sugar can
actually interfere with deep sleep which
will leave you feeling less rested the
next day so just letting to think about
if you are having trouble sleeping let's
take a look at day three the cookie oh
it's just like so melting and put that
on the spoon
was devoured pizza was devoured wings
were devoured chicken strips were
devoured and yet I could still eat I do
however Patrick it cuts how fully Your
Honor on the out of ten I wouldn't eat
much a good cap in this video on a sweet
note their mini after all although the
last video that you saw these in when I
was doing 24 hours eating completely new
things I think you saw me like three on
camera I ate the rest within minutes off
camera and I know that people will kill
me for taking a bite so I'm gonna do
that I do always do this
however because they're so mini you can
literally just put them in your mouth
let me just see if it tastes any
different don't like this anyway I hope
you have enjoyed this full day of eating
okay it is possible that we're dealing
with the extreme hunger that we've
talked about you know when it comes to
other influencers like Stephanie butter
more we're always hungry
as these meals and days look very
similar to theirs I will talk a little
bit more about that very shortly but let
me give you my overall thoughts on this
series of what I eat a days in general
is this way of eating balanced I am
having a lot of mixed feelings watching
a lot of Stephanie's videos and I'm
having a hard time reading them to be
honest on the one hand I love her
enthusiasm for food I also just love
watching her because I think she's got a
real beautiful vibrant energy and is
just super cute and sweet she also made
a specific disclaimer in her day 3 video
about this not being a cheat day so I do
want to let you view that today is no
special day I got get DM from people
asking how often do
days I cannot tell you how that word
hurts my soul I'm not doing a cheat day
I am living my life today it's just
another normal day full day of eating
obviously I'm not saying that I eat
Domino's pizza every single day or every
single Saturday just so happened that we
did actually have Domino's last Saturday
however it's not to say that I'm eating
these things on a particular day if I
want Domino's on and one day I'll have
it on a Monday if I want to date on
Wednesday on Friday on Saturday
it makes no what's to me makes no
difference if I'm training if I'm not
training this isn't a reward for
training or like I'm not gonna feel
guilty tomorrow for having eaten the
Domino's like I'm not gonna go extra
hard at the gym okay so I love this
philosophy and I share it with Stephanie
wholeheartedly so I think it's great
that this day of eating isn't a special
day to Stephanie and that she isn't
going to then restrict heavily the next
day now she also addresses some people's
assumptions that she's bulimic in one of
her videos so I also want to show that
before making any more comments reading
comments at the moment on my videos and
I feel like this is a video where maybe
we can't have this conversation just now
I did it whether to bring this up or not
and given this is a video regarding
mental health specifically eating
disorders let me just point out some of
the things that I get on my videos okay
so someone said something isn't right no
person with the normal relationship to
food gets this excited to eat and
everyone who is commenting on how lucky
she is to have a fast metabolism it's so
naive so I'd said well you don't really
know me that well I eat oats like every
single day yet this seems to me okay
this seems to be food genuinely excites
me and I don't believe well I personally
have never met anyone that shares the
same enthusiasm for food as I do food
for me
there's nothing
it comes between it okay and so for
somebody to then comment and say well
the answer is clearly bulimia is utterly
ridiculous yes as I am fully aware
eating disorders are prevalent and are
very common but at the same time I feel
like if I just can't eat the way I
normally do without somebody having
their assumption be that I have an
eating disorder like where are we
actually headed to this is exactly why I
like to show how ie and I always say
nobody copy how I nobody follow how
anybody else eats because all of our
bodies require completely different
things many of you may be completely
full from the brunch that I had earlier
personally I'm hungry therefore I'm
gonna eat and so for people to comment
and say you know it's got to be bulimia
I really do not believe that that's then
gonna help other people and so I just
want to point out that like use me as an
example if you feel like whoa I'm
overeating because you're following
somebody else who's just eating maybe
like oats for breakfast and then they're
saying oh I'm completely satisfied until
lunch like oats keep me so full and then
you're thinking well like am i abnormal
for wanting to eat a slice of bread two
minutes after my oats No okay so here we
see Stephanie talk about how her
appetite has always been larger than
average and that no two peoples
nutritional needs are the same so you
shouldn't really be comparing yourself
with others that is true and that's a
really important message to share none
of this means that stephanie has an
eating disorder or that she is
necessarily restricting or that she's
throwing up her food none of that is
necessarily truth we don't know that I
don't know that I am admittedly just a
little bit troubled by what to say here
because the reality is I don't know
everything about Stephanie all I see is
the videos that she posts but from what
I do see I do potentially have some
concerns her experience here does remind
me a little bit of Stephanie
better mores extreme hunger as she went
through her all-in journey but from what
we saw with Stephanie's better mores
experience that extreme hunger was a
result of extreme caloric restriction
which totally altered her hunger and
satiety hormones and actually damaged a
number of biological functions it's
actually true that in these
circumstances that is when you have a
history of restriction and associated
low body fat percentage the body may
actually need a drastic amount of
calories to provide basic nutrition for
you know daily needs
plus extra to repair the damage what can
happen is that your enteric nervous
system which is the reflex circuits in
your gut is receiving information that
you're physically full yet the central
nervous system aka your brain is
receiving information that more energy
is required to return to a balanced
state so in this case the drive to eat a
lot of calories even like 10,000
calories which we see in some of these
eating challenge days is very normal in
this circumstance and it should be
honored as it's all about energy
restoration or building back what is
maybe not working optimally there is
good evidence to support this process as
crazy as it may sound to a lot of people
so I will link to some really good
resources below now I want to reiterate
that we don't know if this Stephanie is
restricting on the days that she maybe
isn't showing on her channel like we
know that Stephanie but are more of us
restricting but I just want to share the
information on what we do know about
extreme hunger in general again I'm not
suggesting that this is Stephanie's
experience what I can say is that
between these three 180-day videos never
mind the official eating challenges that
she puts up there is a huge range in
caloric consumption according to our
calculations
Stephanie consumed around 3,000 calories
on day one
1,750 calories on day two and a total of
11,000 430 calories on day 3
that is quite the range and after
looking at her macros her fat intake is
either on the higher end of the 20 to
35% total caloric recommendation or
totally surpasses it now again it is
normal very very normal for us not to
eat the same amount of calories every
day but these discrepancies are pretty
extreme once that he suggested that the
average daily caloric variability for
women should be usually between plus or
minus 25% other total energy needs which
would mean that Stephanie's caloric
intake just based on these three days
would probably sit somewhere between
1650 and 2,750 calories but from these
three videos only one of Stephanies what
Aeneid days actually falls within this
range and I assume if we were to also
factor in a lot of her other eating
challenge videos we would see even a
greater discrepancy also even if
Stephanie is in the bulk phase which I'm
just speculating by her use of hashtags
like hashtag gains on her Instagram her
day 3 contains substantially more food
than what we would probably typically
see and even a man's bulk phase again
everyone's normal needs are super unique
but I'm just speaking to a verges and
patterns that I see I would also say
that even if this variability is normal
for her and is not the result of extreme
hunger or previous restriction which
they very well may be again I cannot
deny her that legitimate possibility I
would have really liked to see her meet
those needs in a more balanced way this
is my major take home sugar salt and
saturated fat are all fine in moderation
but there are days when she's getting
ten times the amount of sodium sixteen
times the amount of saturated fat and
six times the amount of sugar the body
needs like we mentioned excessive intake
of sodium is linked with bloating and
high blood pressure which can put one at
risk for heart disease too much sugar
can also increase the risk of heart
disease as well as other chronic
diseases especially if she's going to
continue with these eating challenges
or even more extreme I would just want
her to be mindful of her everyday usual
normal diet now are there any
problematic claims or assumptions made
by this channel so I actually really
really like Stephanie's attitude towards
food we don't see Stephanie using any
deity language whatsoever in her videos
she also does not seem to be overly
preoccupied with her weight or how much
she eats or what she eats or how many
calories are in what she eats which I
really like I would just flag that again
some of the content in her channel here
may be triggering for a lot of people
who are struggling with their
relationship with food because her
behaviors can read as problematic even
if they are not actually problematic for
her if that makes sense
finally what can we take away from
Stephanie's channel I would say the
biggest takeaway for me is Stephanie's
glowing and fun personality I love that
she loves food and for me she herself is
really a pleasure to watch even if I
sometimes feel a little uncomfortable
watching her kind of eating challenge
days
bottom line though I do appreciate
Stephanie's enthusiasm and openness with
food I do worry about how this may be
interpreted by her viewers who may have
struggled or are currently struggling
with disordered eating or an eating
disorder it is totally healthy and
balanced to enjoy pizza or a matcha
flavored donut from time to time it is
also ok to occasionally eat a lot of
peanut butter off of a spoon but taken
together with the plethora of extreme
eating challenges insatiable hunger and
strange nut butter rituals I'm seeing I
just worry about how it will all be
interpreted by vulnerable viewers I also
think there are definitely much more
balanced ways to get your calories in
even if they are extreme and those
methods don't look like multiple pizzas
ice creams and wings in one sitting well
I do think Stephanie is trying to set a
good example for her followers by
demonstrating that you don't need to be
afraid of food and you can joy food
without being overly preoccupied with
your weight or wrapped up in dye culture
I would have liked to see her
communicate this message physically in a
more balanced and consistent way I want
to conclude by reminding you all to
please be kind in the comments both to
me and to Stephanie if you do choose to
reach out we need to work together to
support people through their eating
journeys not to tear them down and
criticize them for being wrong there is
no right or wrong in the situation we're
all just using our own unique set of
coping strategies to get by and on that
note that is all for today's video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you would like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]